despite all the hard that you're
going through you just have to believe
with all your heart that you're
going to make it welcome to the one of
zero Show episode one advice for hard
days I'll be taking questions for you
guys in the audience and we'll be doing
this
live Alex what's up what's going on man
how we doing I'm rocking hey dude first
and for most man I know you probably
heard this a thousand times over but
thank you and uh not only for doing
something like this but um the impact uh
that you're making on people's lives I
think you probably have a number of idea
of a number of lives that you're
impacting but you could just take that
and multiply it by a thousand and that's
real talk big number well I appreciate
it man thank you what can I help you
with man uh not much man I mean I guess
not much and also a lot but uh yeah no
so uh I run a group and personal
training gym in uh in Jersey and it's um
basically our tools are kettle bells
Community breath work and the focus for
me is longevity and uh the one question
that I had that's been brewing in my
mind since I'm pretty early in my career
in the sense of two years coming up on
three years
um is what's the one question that you
wish you would have asked yourself
earlier in your entrepreneurial
career when faced with a little bit of
uncertainty and
Direction and I know that's probably
Hefty question and like just to give you
context for myself too it's
like 90% of my business is in person um
in terms of online that's the kind of
the the direction of whether or not I
really want to go towards um more
specifically you know creating almost
like a watify version of kettle Bell's
um platform you know so it's um just
basically just trying to figure out what
the next step is going to be you
know h
okay so I
guess me asking myself a question is
always going to be different than you
asking something for you because we're
different people right and we have
different goals and so everything
usually ladds up to like what's the goal
what's the why and so like right now do
you have like a monetary goal do you
have an impact goal and believe me I
have no issues if you're like I just
want to make a certain amount of money
like I get that um because any of the
businesses that you just mentioned so
whether it's the brick and mortar uh
business or you want to start doing
training for those people online or it's
doing the watify version which is
basically no service and just providing
workouts and whatnot um all of those are
are potential businesses but pursuing
all of them at the same time will
virtually guarantee that you don't
succeed at any of them and so the
biggest issue when you're starting out
is just picking the path and being
willing to commit to it with the
uncertainty that comes with it because
like every entrepreneurial path has
uncertainty like and that's what makes
entrepreneurship hard it's literally the
not knowing and the pain of suffering
consequences for ignorance for things
that you've learned now that you're like
if I had only known then what I know now
and that's every entrepreneur until the
day they
die and it's just wishing that it were
different that causes a lot of the
struggle so which of these things of the
three that I just mentioned like which
of those is the one that like lights you
up the
most um I mean in-person training
obviously like we live in a small Beach
toown Community where everybody knows
everybody and it's fun it's family it's
convenient I will say there's that
comfort factor that in almost in one
scope is very beneficial because it is
so comfortable but in reality too like
Comfort is the enemy of achievement and
growth so it's like I know like the
comfortable side is the inperson and
it's the community and it's fun it's
family friends whereas the uncomfortable
more challenging but also very big
picture-wise would be the online going
Full Tilt that side now i' I've breached
into the gap of like three day launches
four day launches of you know small
ticket low ticket offers but in terms of
you know trying to scale and make an
impact on the world yeah then the
world's really big that so that's always
really hard because I remember I had a
we had an event with gym owners and
somebody stood up I said what's your
mission they're like I want to impact
One Million Lives I was like do you have
a birk and mortar location that has like
200 members like let's want to do that
then you would actually just you would
you you You' approach it very
differently or you'd have a Time rise
and that's the rest of your life right
it's like one or the other if you're
like I want to do that in three years
you wouldn't start with a brick Mor
location and so the thing is is that
what you said earlier is like you you
feel comfortable and it sounds like you
want to grow I just want to make sure
that's correct before I like absolutely
okay
so there there was like an underlying
assumption at least that was unspoken
and I just want to draw attention to it
which was you're like the brick and
mortar thing is comfortable it's family
it's friendly it's fun I'm assuming it's
profitable I'm assuming you're making
some money doing that um the thing is is
like you could like just doing more of
what you're currently doing and saying
like how do I open a second location or
how do I you know like how do I open
like five locations over the next five
years or whatever whatever it is yeah
that would produce probably just as much
of a challenge as going online would
except you already have two years of
learnings on how to run that business
where you have none in the online space
yeah and so like you always just want to
Stack knowledge within a specific
vertical so that you just go deeper and
deeper on it because that's where the
compounding returns happen like the
richest people that I know have been in
the same space for 40 years they just
know everything there is to know about
the space and like that's how they've
made their money and so with what you're
doing like you can either open a
location that's not necessarily an Beach
down and test your metal and see how
good you are at actually scaling a team
you know hiring somebody else seeing if
somebody else if you can actually
incentivize people build a culture so
that people want to work for you that
you can recreate the success and that'll
show you whether the success that you
had was because of you or because of
your ability as a as a businessman right
because like you can be a charismatic
razzled Dazzle dancing bear in any
brick-and mortar business and it will
work yeah it'll work surface with a
smile always always works right and it's
just hard to scale because most people
don't care as much as owners do but if
you can create the model that has the
incentives and the training in place and
the and the procedures that can
consistently create that five out of
five experience that allow a second
location to have the same amount of
success as your first location then you
have something that absolutely can scale
and create lots of Enterprise Value over
time so I would say either scale that or
basically dial down your inperson to as
little as humanely possible of your time
and then go in on the online thing but
uh trying to do both will be very hard
because what'll happen is you'll start
to do some online stuff you'll start to
subtraction your gym will start going
down but that's your main source of
income then you'll hop back to the gym
the online will dip and you'll go back
and forth and so that's why I'm so big
on just committing to whatever thing is
because any of them would work but you
just have to be all in on it yeah and I
know we're running out of time but I
guess on that point too it's like the
one pillar that I guess I failed to
mention was the freedom and
flexibility this being a seasonal town
and do the other thing and haven't gone
to the gym for a year then maybe you'll
do the you'll do a second gym and so I
think no matter what path you do this is
probably perfect end for this which is
you either are going to do the online
thing after you figure out how to
Outsource the gym or delegate it and
hire people who are awesome or you
decide you're going to do a second um
location either way you're gonna have to
start with Outsourcing the first gym
that's two STS one two stone or two
birds one stone
yeah appreciate you AJ appreciate you Bo
keep doing it
later hey
Alex what's up how do you say your name
hod
hod yeah pretty good how are you doing
good man good good so uh first of all
really appreciate the uh chance that you
uh gave me uh this is this means a lot
to me um so I'll just jump into into the
question so um let's say I um I want to
start a business okay and
um there
are I can have a very Grand Vision of
the business so like apple or Microsoft
they they had this vision of like
changing the whole world okay um but but
I also can have a vision of just just
making enough money for me to survive
and just work on my thing um let's for
now assume that I've that I've chosen
the Grand Vision one okay um how so the
the real question here is how do we keep
working on this business for years when
we're worried that it might get outdated
because of a new AI or a technology or
in other words what do we do when we
think our project might not be useful in
the long run I mean what you're talking
about is strategy
like these are strategic decisions that
we have to make like you make a big bet
on where you think the market is going
to be not where it is today if you're
going to go after something that's that
big but do do you have investors right
now uh no I'm I'm a entrepreneur if you
you say that then let's let's bring this
back down to earth all right just for
just for your own sake
um if you look at the companies that you
just referenced right like you look at
basos with Amazon you look at you know
Zuckerberg you look at Microsoft every
one of those guys started well off and
well
capitalized okay so basos was a
investment banker from Wall Street Bill
Gates parents were really well off and
he was well off and whatnot Zuckerberg
went to Harvard same deal and so like I
you if you want to really go after that
you would have to try and recreate the
conditions and I think that right now
the likelihood that that happens given
your current situation is low and I'm
not saying that to dissuade you I'm
saying because I want to be realistic
with you which is that you need to get
your own head above water because like
right now if you're if you don't have
the ability to make money on your own
right from a entrepreneurial perspective
like you need to get your head above
water because the only way that you
could stick with something for the
required amount of time in order for it
to become world changing like we're not
talking even a decade I mean those
companies they're you know 20 Facebook's
20 something years old right just like
context and so the only way to get there
uh is be able to breathe while you're
going and so I think that from a a
one-on-one perspective starting starting
a simple business that you can generate
income on that you know you can you can
learn the basics of business before
trying to take on the biggest
competitors in the most well-
capitalized Arena absolutely on your
own I
see not to say that that's impossible
it's just incredibly improbable given
the the circumstances that you just laid
out okay it would be really romantic for
me to be like dude go chase your dreams
go do that but like I also would rather
have you in a year making money on your
your own so that you can breathe because
you might find out that if you actually
start making money on your own you might
just like that because right now it's
just the idea of the status of the dream
that like it's an amorphous idea but the
amount of pain and suffering that you
have to be able to put up with and not
make money through that whole period of
time really
tough okay but but wouldn't that uh
wouldn't that cause another issue where
because you you decide to choose a pro
choose to solve a problem that is small
like smaller than the grand Vision uh
then you won't be able to scale much
that's not necessarily true and also
every one of those companies starts
small like Facebook wasn't like we want
to be the social media platform for the
whole world he wanted to map
colleges yeah they s they start with a
niche and then they expand outwards and
so you want to much more narrowly Define
your problem before you go attack it
because what you're going to try and do
is build something that's going to be
everything for everyone and it's gonna
be nothing for
nobody I see you are strategy is
prioritization it's allocating limited
resources against unlimited options and
so you have unlimited options but you
have very limited resources and so in
order to be successful you have to
narrow the problem that you're trying to
solve so you can allocate the small
amount of resources you have to
adequately solve that problem completely
and then from adequately solving that
problem completely like Amazon started
with books and Facebook started with
colleges right you solve and then you
can go adjacent right so right now it
just sounds exciting to say this but
like it's not reality you have to pick
one problem that you're gonna get really
good at solving and that's it and then
you can have an idea that in the future
but real real so many things are going
to change between now and then and
there's so much luck that that that has
to concur because if you think about
this zooming all the way out the biggest
companies in the world have super well
capitalized people who are the best in
the
world made a good call and had luck
because if you're number one you have
all the things plus luck like if you're
number one at like in the whole world
it's all of it plus luck the market
moves in a direction that M that you
never know right and so I I would rather
you just stick to a problem that you
know you can absolutely solve given the
resources you have learn the skills make
income and then from there you can go
solve an adjacent problem or you might
decide you know what I like this and I'm
gonna keep going with
it I see thank you very much that's that
was really awesome thank you than good
luck man you too thank
you all right so this is our first uh
tweet break interruption or not
Interruption just tweet tweet tweet
Central um you're going to lose sleep
you'll doubt whether it'll work you'll
stress to make ends meet you won't
finish your to-do list you wonder if you
made the right call and have no way to
know for years this is what hard feels
like and that's okay um when I was
tweeting that I was thinking to myself
about I think it was just stuff that I
was going through at the moment so if
you guys don't know like my tweets
actually just they're not they're not
ghost ridden they're just me and they
come throughout the day like right
before I got here uh Jason grabbed my
phone I was like wait I got to tweet
this something just came on my head um
and I think I think I was just just
trying because a lot of people say like
entrepreneurship is hard but I was like
it's such a it's such a vague term I was
like what what about it makes it
difficult and the the thing that I keep
coming back to that makes
entrepreneurship difficult is that you
have a known cost for an unknown payoff
you know every day that you're
continuing to pay these bills both in
time energy money all of it every day
you're paying this bill right but you
don't get the paycheck back you don't
get the reward back and sometimes it's a
week sometimes it's a month sometimes
it's a year and sometimes more
realistically it's years plural before
you get the paycheck back and the
paycheck isn't always money sometimes
it's just knowing that the thing you
said was going to happen happens or that
maybe your wife looks at you a different
way or maybe it's your your family that
looks at you different way you want
status with with your community whatever
it is um whatever that thing is that
paycheck that you're working for
figuratively um and it just comes down
to this absolute Soul crushing
uncertainty with the idea that no one
can actually tell you and you have this
this unquenched desire to be able to
predict the future while at the same
time knowing that you can and you have
this desire because every day you learn
something and then you look back at a
year from a year a year ago and you're
like why the hell did I not know this
like I'm such an idiot it feels like I'm
starting all over again today because of
what I just recently learned all the
work that I did up to this point is
useless but that's the wrong way to see
it because like you are the work that
you've been working on entire time and
the fact that you can see what you were
doing before was not nearly as fruitful
as it could have been is the progress
that you are making and so like trying
to consistently reframe that for myself
has been uh really powerful in getting
through harder
times Jimmy let's go to the next
one DJ oh my gosh hi you're amazing I
can't believe I'm talking to you thank
you socome yes I love you
um I do like I had to get that out I
love you back yes so I run a writing
company I write for celebrities and CEOs
because I took your advice and I started
writing for people that have more money
and it's oh
gosh yes um but I also publish my own
books and I traditionally published with
Publishers and I've done really well but
in the future going forward I want to
publish my own book self-publish my own
book because that's just it's it's
necessary right yeah but I have analysis
paralysis because there's so many
options to execute a
strategy sometimes I don't know which
option to pick to just execute the
strategy for my next book and my first
goal is just to sell a thousand ebook
copies not nothing even Grand yeah okay
then when I settle on a strategy I get
scared because I don't know if it's
going to work like when I set on oh I'm
just going to use like clickfunnels and
D then I'm like oh but I don't know if
it's going to work and then right and
then I'm back into the same place the
hard times place and then I do nothing
yeah understood so two questions real
quick so when you say you have so many
different strategy you can pick from
you're talking about different topics
for the book is that what you're saying
no so I know the book topic but
different options to execute a plan so I
could use Quick clickfunnels to execute
a plan to sell a thousand s yeah just
selling it yeah just selling the
Thousand copies that's that that's my
goal I want to be able to sell a
thousand copies for my next
self-published book have you read the
book yet have you written the book yet
no but the book will be that's the easy
part okay I'm a writer so that's the
easy part okay okay okay um because I
was like I'm like the book's the hard
part selling's the easy part um opposite
problem for me yeah no understood okay
so um you you want to have a guarantee
you're asking the world for a guarantee
you're asking yeah you're asking the
universe for a guarantee that it will
never give you yes and you're waiting
for a response in order to move forward
from a universe that stays silent yep
right and so you're just talking to dead
people um and waiting for a response so
like um the thing is the person you
should be talking to is the marketplace
because they will always respond like
when you knock they will open the door
and they will tell you to off or
they you open the door and they'll tell
you they'll let you in but either way
they'll open the door right um and
so I mean let's play this out the other
way
what are you afraid
of because like you seem very upbeat and
you see like obviously you've written
this you've written stuff before yeah a
lot of tons not worried about your
writing skill given what you've said so
far so like what are you afraid of okay
so let's let's play it out so let's say
you you have your book and you pick path
one it doesn't matter what it is pick
path one okay so what so what happens so
you put it on Amazon you're like I'm
just gonna put it on Amazon and see what
happens all right that's the easy path
okay then
what yeah I'm I'm scared that I won't
reach my number I'm scared that fail at
the goal and then then what
happens I I mean I'll
survive but but then I still won't know
how to do it like and and I'm also
scared because I have self-published a
couple books in the past that didn't
reach my goal okay and I know that feels
like I don't want to feel like that
again yeah so let me so let me do this
then let's reframe this because I have a
lot of experience with setting goals
right so I feel pretty confident talk
about the topic especially big goals
make the big goals that you set things
that you can absolutely control like you
cannot control how many people buy your
book but you can control the amount of
actions that you're willing to take that
make it unreasonable that you don't sell
a thousand copies and so then you can
judge how successful you were by how
much you adhered to the actions that you
committed
to and so if I were to say you have to
sell 10,000 books not a thousand books
10,000 books you have to or you lose
your life in 12 months you just die
that's it you die what would you
do knock on every door okay okay like
you're thinking about it right like you
have the leads book right there all
there's eight different ways to
advertise yeah right and so you know
that the more people find out about your
stuff the more people buy it and there's
only four things you can do right you
can talk to people 10 one you can make
content you can run ads yeah right where
you get other Affiliates you can get
referrals once they read your book or
you can get agencies or can get
employees to help you out that's what
you got yes okay and so if you know that
you have to take those
actions then wouldn't success be so
let's play this out a year let's say
that you did absolutely everything on
the plan like your plan of advertising
of letting people know about it for a
year and you did everything and you sold
999 bucks would you consider it a
failure no that would be a win okay now
if you sold 90
books that what's crazy is that it's
just a number no I
know but I just want to reframe this
because the honestly the thing that
you're talking about is something that
so many people deal with and it's
because you want to control things you
want to control the outcome and you're
saying I'm only willing to pay this
price if there's this outcome but you're
seeing the outcome as the outcome rather
than the skills that you develop along
the way as the outcome because I can
promise you this this will not be the
the last book you write right and so if
you get to a hundred sales instead of a
thousand then what's going to happen
realistically is that you will figure
out the one thing or two things that
actually work to sell books and then
I'll say do a hundred times more of that
and you can either choose to do that on
this book or you can choose to do it on
the next book but the idea of like I
have I'm setting this thous because you
could have set a million books it
doesn't really matter you're just
setting it you're making up a number and
saying this I feel is reasonable for me
yeah instead of making the number
reasonable make the actions that would
lead to that the reason like what can
you commit to four hours a day of
promotion yeah okay then make that the
commitment and I will if you do that
every day one at the end of the year you
will feel accomplished because you
actually did what you said you were
gonna do that the marketplace will also
always recognize someone who puts four
hours of work every single day into one
thing
yeah and that you can
control right don't do my best do as
required that's right might not be good
enough that that's true man that was
amazing just what I needed thank you
good just promise me that you'll
actually just commit to doing the work
yes if you do that you do like I have to
get sell 10,000 books what would I
actually do to do that yeah find
somebody who has an audience that is
relative to the topics that you're
talking about out to that now it's okay
if I got one person they sold 20 books
okay how do I reach out to a thousand
people all have my audience if you do
that you'll probably sell more than a
thousand books but you just got to do it
four hours every day okay cool yes thank
you thank you I love you you're the best
you're man love you good luck with the
book appreciate
it what's
up hey Alex how are you doing good man
nice hat thank you I like it quite a lot
look
felt oh my God it's the best hat for the
gym good so what's up man awesome man so
I have two topics that I kind of want to
you know trade with you and you know you
titled this advice for hard days and
it's been it's been tough lately uh so
I'm just going to catch you up on a
little a couple of things that are
happening so right about three months
ago uh my grandmother was diagnosed with
cancer two months ago uh my girlfriend
the the girl that I T I was going to
marry kind of left and then two weeks
ago uh I traveled to London to speak at
Europe's biggest business event and on
the first day of my arrival my granddad
passed away and so uh I had to basically
uh speak in front of thousands of people
and keep my smile and and then travel
back and burry him did so yesterday I I
did I did I did all of it and so the
question is well you know yesterday
everything just kind of hit me because
now I'm back in the office and I'm
taking the calls and I'm trying to deal
with everything but the question is how
do I maintain my composure and kind of
stay strong right because it's it's a
tough period totally well first off I'm
sorry that you're going through that um
that being said honestly you've got a
lot of good stuff going for you so this
is a I feel like almost a relatively
easier one for me to take given what you
just said okay like you just asked a
question how do I do something I've
already done
before which is you got in front of a
thousands of people and gave a
presentation and had a smile and you
crushed it despite the fact that you had
other circumstances right yeah and so
you ask the question how do I do
something that I already
done you've already done
it yeah like what you're saying is how
do I how do I keep living and you keep
living by keeping living it's the same
thing with breakups right it's like I
I've heard this quote and I I heard it
from Lila I think the first time like
the amount of time it takes you get over
someone do you know how long it
is's it doesn't matter it depends
there's a great math equation for it
you'll love it it's exactly as long as
you decide it takes
yeah and what I'm going to say is going
to sound really dark right now so I want
you to take this the right way take it
the way I mean it right which is that
you just had you had three deaths right
you had death of a life that you thought
you were GNA have with a girlfriend and
then you had the death of uh two
different grandparents right you three
deaths but wow uh on the positive sides
my my grandmother is still battling with
it oh okay she's still B wait we're
we're plus one all right so only two
deaths now right but sure we can even
play it out all right on a long enough
time riseon she will eventually pass
away right it's going to happen yeah and
the thing is is that you are already
standing
it like you're asking how do I stand it
but you are standing here
already like you are evidence to the
fact you are you you talking to me today
is evidence of the success that you're
asking
for you're already one dude you're
showing up and you're working every day
you're coming here to ask questions to
actually still trying to grow yourself
like the the stuff that you go through
become the stories that you will someday
tell and no one likes epic Heroes
without Epic monsters and so you have to
go through the rocky cut scene you have
to have those periods of time where you
doubt yourself or everyone else doubts
yourself where the walls are crumbling
around you because have you ever read
shoe dog fil night story about Nike even
if you haven't the the entire story is
just him getting kicked in the nuts for
30 years it's the whole story and then
he's like oh yeah then I built Nike
right and now if he had just said yeah
um I started this company and everyone
loved it and all my suppliers were on
time and I just scaled straight and as
the money came in I just bought more
inventory and then we just went public
no one would care because it's not
relatable and the thing is is that when
you die the only thing that will remain
is the story that people will tell of
you and so wouldn't you want that to be
an epic story
yeah and so the things that you're going
through are required for the person you
want to be and for the goals that you
have and how you are acting in the
present already proves the thing that
you're claiming that you
want so you're already W
dude and you're G to just stand it by
tomorrow you're going to wake up and
you're go to
work and the next day you're going to
wake up and go to work and then you're
going to text and it's going to say that
your grandmother's cancer is getting
worse and what are you going to do
you're going to get back to work work
you're just going to keep doing the
stuff like there's no there's no magic
bullet you just keep going because
either you keep going or you
die yeah and if you don't die you
succeeded got it just don't judge
yourself on how you feel judge yourself
by what you do despite how you feel so
you can feel shitty you can wake up and
have a terrible day and still show up
with a smile in front of the thousand
people and so if you can do it with a
thousand people you can do it with one
and that first one is the person that
looks at you in the mirror in the
morning if you can do it for them you
can do it for
you got it got it yeah well that that
was kind of like the the Life part and
and now when it comes to business I just
have a real quick question okay uh so
I've built an Instagram audience to over
100,000 I speak about sales and
marketing
I've been doing it for the past two
years I've been posting kind of like
every day I know the content game but
the one thing that I'm struggling to
balance is you know how you say give
give give until they ask and you know I
love it but
sometimes you know it takes a while
until they ask right and cash flow still
needs to come in and I run h a service
based uh business and so how do I
balance it out without tiring my
audience because I so my community is
known for you know really being in the
comments chatting with me and being
there for me so how do I do it that
balance line so if you want to have a
one step away from like just giving
forever right is that you you give in
public sell in private which is when
people respond to your stories right
when people DM you like those are
conversations that they're usually
asking or they're like they're basically
ask when people ask questions there you
can't still Define a scope and say hey
like at a certain point I have like I've
given you all this value use all the
free stuff if you want more than that
I'd be happy to hop on a call and see if
I can help you more right so it's not
it's not like everyone buy this thing
right now right you're not you're not
like getting super aggressive about you
still publicly just keep pumping all the
Goodwill in the value that you are and
that'll grow your audience and increase
Goodwill and all those things that's
what you want you're G to keep doing
that it's just that you could still have
a call to action that's just in the in
the in the comment section or put a
story up that says hey by the way if you
need help with that thing um I'm happy
to help like those are those are very
light touch things because I understand
you got to pay bills I understand that
and so you can put those things out
without necessarily damaging the
Goodwill that I think you're that you're
that you're obviously
building yeah that was that was kind of
like the the one thing that that I had
in mind well I don't want to take more
of your time but that was fantastic yeah
irresistible yeah so good if saying no I
got it 100 million offers that's
right thank you I appreciate you man
you're fantastic you are too man hang in
there you'll be fine you'll get through
it and then it'll be a story that you'll
someday tell yeah and thank you for
everything that you do not just for me
but for everyone else because I think
you're marking A New Path uh and that's
that's kind of cool I appreciate you
brother thank
you all right if you have your back
against the wall and you have nothing
left it also means you have nothing to
lose and that makes a very dangerous
person which is why there will always be
room for the underdog you know I think
this is really interesting um because I
think I tweeted this because someone had
recently commented or said or I saw
YouTube comment where someone was like I
don't have anything uh there's why is
there even a point to this like why even
bother because I don't have any of the
advantages or whatever of XYZ person so
there's a couple directions to take that
so if you're one of these people and
I'll throw this out there like right now
if I were to say Hey wen't you
succeeding the way you want to right you
would insert whatever excuses you have
you're like my mom doesn't help me or I
did I wasn't born in the right
neighborhood or I'm born across the
country whatever it is right the natural
response to that question is okay you're
right you will never
succeed now what well we got to do
something right right so here we are
again back to doing something right
because it doesn't matter like the all
the reasons that we give don't matter
because they're they only change your
behavior in so far as you allow them to
stop you from doing things and so the
laws of action and consequence will
always preside and so you can do stuff
even if you don't deserve it even if you
were born in the wrong neighborhood with
the wrong people and still get the thing
that doing the action gets you right and
the interesting thing to me is that the
people who have the least also have the
least to lose which makes them the most
dangerous competitors because as soon as
you have something you become more RIS
averse you can't take the same gambl
like I don't take the same G G now as I
did when I started why because I have
something to lose right but if you have
nothing to lose then it's basically like
life giving you uh a scratch off lottery
ticket and you saying you don't want to
scratch it off because you don't want to
lose but they're giving you the lottery
ticket for free because what happens you
get the lottery ticket and you lose and
where are you just as poor and still
having nothing just like you did before
but in that one ticket out of 20 or 100
or a thousand tickets which is phone
calls reaching outs knocking on doors
sending cold emails whatever that lot
ticket
is you can get one yes and it can change
your life and so it's like why would you
not take the lottery ticket and so it's
interesting because a lot of people want
the yes but they aren't willing to pay
the price for yes because the price for
yes is a 100 Nos and as soon as you are
willing to get the 100 NOS you can get
as many yeses as you damn well
please
what's up it's a man the myth the legend
Alex man the legend black tank looks
nice what's up oh thanks man I have to
copy you over here I don't look as
jacked as you so on that good
Li all right so my question is basically
I've been online fitness coach for the
last like three years now and like even
progressing from like the first 10K
month like three years ago like 25k a
month a couple months ago I kind of felt
like I got loner the more successful I
got even though I do have a pretty big
audience now like over one million
followers
acrosser got yeah so across Facebook
YouTube Tik Tok and Instagram itself
like it just maybe you went through
something that something like that or
maybe you haven't in that sense I was
just wondering like maybe how you got
over that self-limiting belief because I
feel like that's kind of holding me back
I want to make sure that I'm I want to
clearly understand your question so
you're saying that being lonely is the
thing that is holding you
back well it was more like I know
Lifestyle Changes oh obviously you're
going to lose friends along the way the
conversation is a lot different in that
sense but just like especially from
going in person and being a full-time in
person training and going line top of
that just like a lot more lonely kind in
a lot of different aspects of losing
that kind of
touch you just need you just have to
join a community man like just straight
up like you just need you just need to
get around people doing the same thing
as you and so that might mean physically
moving to a different area because right
now I'm assuming online pay like pays
your bills
correct yeah right so if online pays
your bills then you can literally be
anywhere in the world and so if you
where you live right now I'm Emon
Alberta I'm planning to move to Colona
it's more of like a fitness town in
Canada in like two months time like that
big reason because I know more Fitness
people doing out there so I feel like
that would be a big help to you I would
do that and I would also join a bunch of
online communities of people who are
like trying to make money in the fitness
space because you'll find a ton of other
people who were doing the same thing as
you that are on the path that are ahead
of you that're the same as you that are
behind you and you you get a little bit
of some some fulfillment from helping
out some of the people behind you but
you can also get help from the people
ahead of you um who are you know because
you show that you'll you'll execute and
you'll do what they say um and you'll
and you'll grow but this is the nice
news is that this problem is super
solved like you just got to get around
people and you got to be willing to
rejected yeah it's just like friend
sales it's the same thing just go you go
you go on a bunch of dates they're just
friend dates you know go hang out go get
a lift in I mean it's Fitness so like
just go ask a bunch of people to get a
lift in and you'll see who's cool and
you'll see who isn't worst
case yeah have you ever kind of
experienced that as you kind of leveled
up and leveled up I know of
course but as long as you keep growing
this is not going to stop you're going
to find new friends and if you keep
growing you'll pass them and then you'll
find new friends that are above them and
you'll pass them and you'll just keep
going um and so it just depends on how
like what you see the role of friends as
in your life and so you know for me I
just want my requirement for friend
isn't necessarily that they make the
same or more money than me at all is do
they make me
better do they make me better do they
have my best intentions in all just
already two incredibly difficult things
to pass but if someone passes both those
things then they are a friend
and so I would just use that as a limit
test like is this person making me
better and do they have my best you know
incentive at
heart yeah and how is making friends I
guess now because obviously you're a
higher level and things are different
with social status and all that vers
four is probably different so do you
kind of have the same standards now kind
of like what is what is it kind of like
dude it's harder for me than it is for
you
yeah um no for real it is but the thing
is is that I most of the my closest
friends don't live here like don't live
in the same physical area that I do most
of the closest friends that I have live
all over and so I see most of my friends
once or twice a
year and that's it and I work in the
meantime the thing is is that like the
higher up you go here like and I'll just
tell you something like from My Level
whatever you want to call that um all
the friends I have everyone complet like
there is zero social obligations for
anything like none and if I don't
respond to text for 3 days there is zero
drama it's not even acknowledged it's
just we know that busy people understand
that busy people are doing and so
if everyone you have everyone who's
who's in your world understands that
you're trying to take this hill then if
they're truly your friend then they want
you to take the hill more than they want
you to respond to their text or come out
with them for
the like I just got invited to a 7-Day
thing that um with a with a couple
friend that LE and I both really really
adore um
but we'll probably not be able to do it
because we have so much stuff that we
were that we're doing at that same time
and I really want to go but I also
really want to do this other stuff and I
know that I will feel worse about myself
if I don't have this other stuff done
and so we're gonna say that I can't go
and that's going to be it and they're
not going to hold it against
me and so until you find friends who are
100% aligned with you achieving your
goals who are making you better and you
goals then you just keep looking but the
thing is like everybody goes period that
you're at like I think I I think I made
I wrote a tweet about this but like
there is this lonely period that always
happens when you start growing because
it happens is that you're too big for
the old friend group but you're not
quite big enough for the group that you
want to get into right so you kind of
have this path in the Middle where you
just kind of like keep trudging along
but like every single person who's
accomplished anything material has been
in your exact same
shoes and you just keep going and you
keep going you keep networking you enter
you go into the communities you see the
people who are adding value to those
communities and you message them you
find the givers because givers recognize
givers almost immediately you can see
the people who are always giving more
above and beyond and you can understand
they get the
game and so like in that first meeting
if they're like like let me see if I can
do this for you let me like take care of
this for you let me help you in this way
rather than like hey could you help me
with this like wrong person but if you
just start by giving to a whole bunch of
people who are where you want to be
you'll get more back even if nine out of
10 don't give you anything
back okay that was very helpful over
there especially I mean with the
community side of moving definitely kind
helps and just giving to those groups
and those are kind of people especially
want to kind be around if you give out a
lot publicly the people who message you
privately will be people who recognize
what you were
providing and so like be loud provide
shitloads of value people will message
you and then be like hey let's hop on a
zoom let's grab a zoom lunch whatever
and so like you can have a ton of
friends dates or whatever that you meet
people and see if they have game and if
they have game then you keep in touch
because you're making them better
too yeah you also said that pretty much
all your friends are kind of around the
world I know it's a little different
itself you kind of feel like you almost
lose a little bit of that Personal Touch
then or no of course it's just a
trade it's a
trade so it's like if you're willing to
make the trade then I mean like I'll put
it this way if that were the price that
you had to pay to live the life that you
want to live would you pay it that you
just have friends that you meet up with
once a
month
yes then that's just the price tag and
those are the Nikes you can pay the 500
or not but that's the price
tag all right appreciate everything you
bet brother you kill the content Game
Change it's amazing got see fly
everything down spinge all your stuff
keep it up bro I appreciate it man thank
you
we rolling this
Tuesday hey Alex how's it going all
right tell me how do I say your name
celesi oh that's easy celesi all right
what's up celesi what's up Alex hey
thank you so much for having me on here
um so I'll get right into my question so
after doing full-time entrepreneurship
for three years right um and you know
raising a family I got four four small
children all under the age of five I
found myself in a very hard position
where I had to go back to a ninet to-5
I'm actually at my nin to I'm I'm at my
ninet to-5 right now
sobody so now I'm like I'm like in a
place that like you know like I would
say entrepreneurship is like like you
said it's hard and and I know what hard
feels like but after discussing it with
my wife like I felt like this was like
the right decision
after getting myself into business debt
and other things like that
and I didn't never have a paycheck to
live on you know so how do I know when
it's like like how do I get back into
entrepreneurship like now I'm just
running my stuff on the side so for
example right when I was laid off uh
three years ago I was doing taxes and I
just doing like um bookkeeping and then
I worked my way up starting to offer
accounting services and then I leveled
up and I started look going after higher
leverage like now I started doing CFO
services and um I went through that
Valley of Despair thing and that's
probably why I'm at where I'm at right
now you know okay um just being
completely honest and and now I'm
like you're good no I said you're good
man like don't worry like I I I I
appreciate you being candidate upfront
about it because otherwise this wouldn't
be very valuable because You' tell me a
bunch of fake information and I'll give
you a response to fake information it
wouldn't matter for either of us so
thank you for being honest um that being
said you're not honestly you're in a
pretty good spot and I'll tell you why
so you have a valuable skill set that
will always be in demand because a lot
of people don't want to do money stuff
so people don't do budgets people don't
do bookkeeping people don't do CFO work
people do financials projections
forecast no one wants to do any of that
stuff and you do and you're good at it
so presumably you're good at because you
keep doing it right I'll just I'll leave
it at that I'm gonna assume that for the
sign for call right so um one I think it
was wise that you got a job because you
have a wife you have four kids I think
that was a smart Noggin move okay now
that being said there's going to be a
conversation that you probably have to
have with your wife about
what because your nights and weekends
either are going to have to go to family
or they're going to have to go to the
new
thing and so I think that you need to
have a candy conversation with her and
say listen my Prim and I'm just I'm
putting words in your mouth here so this
is if I wear your shoes I would say as a
man my primary drive is to
provide and right now I feel like I'm
failing you and I want
to lead our children by example so that
when they are 20 or 30 and they're
thinking about making that jump I can
speak to it because I wasn't afraid to
take the risk again because in
gymnastics as soon as you fall off the
pommel horse even if you twist or break
your ankle you know what they do they
try and get you right back on the horse
again and they do that because if you
don't and you take enough time off you
start developing these fears around
getting back on you never get on again
and so they want you to get back on the
horse right now I think you got bucked
by the entrepreneurial horse and that's
okay it happens it's part of the game
right like it's the it's the the scene
in Rocky 17 or whatever Rocky it
is where he's like it's not about how
hard you can hit about but it's about
hard you can get hit and keep going
forward right and so you got hit big you
know big whoop everybody gets hit
everyone loses all the time I
lost everything twice before this time
right and so like you've lost everything
once you still you still owe me one
right you can tell your wife I said that
and so let's get into tactics all right
so right now the in my opinion the issue
that you miss is you didn't know how to
advertise you didn't know how to promote
and so you have the service you just got
to let people know about it and so you
were full-time as an entrepreneur but
you probably weren't spending four hours
a day promoting and you're 100% correct
right so that's that's what you need to
do so nights and weekends for you is you
log out of work go home kiss the dog
high five the kids and then you spend
four hours promoting and promoting is
you make content you reach out to people
or you run ads and given your financial
situation it's going to be making
content and reaching out to people
that's it literally if that's what
you're you start your timer four hours
you make content you reach out to people
and you do that for four straight hours
every day you do that you're gonna have
more business in the next six months you
even know know to do
it dang that's it that's all you have to
do like you the thing is you're in a
good spot because you have the skill
that there's already demand like I don't
have to test your idea you're trying to
provide bookkeeping services it's a
commoditized service like if you do a
good job you're on time like you are
responsive you deliver things on the
first of the month people will want to
do business with you and they'll stay
with you and so you just got to let
people know about it faster because I'm
guessing that your rate was based on
referrals you had one or two customers
maybe three and by the time you get one
new referral every two or three months
one would drop and you stayed there
until eventually you couldn't right I'm
guessing that was the story right so you
just need to increase your sales
velocity which means you got to let more
people know about it and you got to
learn how to sell because it was just
you right did you have employees no I
had a virtual assistant during tax
season but yeah it was mainly just me
yeah then you have the easiest business
in the world because 100% of the revenue
is profit right it's just you for now
and so you can absolutely get yourself
to 10 20 accounting clients and you're
gonna be working like a dog at this
point but you'll be making way more than
you are now and then you'll have new
problems because then your wife's like I
don't see you anymore you're like yeah
but now we're making three times money
and I will find a way to use the money
to buy back some time and you can do
that but idea like you're you're like
you already have the hard done
you're like six months away seriously
like I don't normally say that like
you're six months away you gota you got
to reach out to let's call it let's call
it 10,000 people okay you reach out to
10,000 people you'll have the you'll
have the business you
want got it even if you suck you'll have
the business you want if reach out to
10,000 people and just ask them if they
need help with that thing because I'm
telling you right now as a business
owner dude the amount of
crappy accountants and bookkeepers that
out there outnumber the good ones 100 to
one like no one's stoked about their
bookkeeper so like like it's not hard
and like think about it those guys don't
like those guys suffer the same issue
that you have is they don't know how to
promote themselves they're not business
people they're Bean counters and so like
you you've been you've been in bean
counter mode and you got to get in you
got to get in promoter mode especially
as a as a solo entrepreneur it's all
promotion in the
beginning so would you suggest just
mainly cold Outreach or should I try to
do content or just go straight cold
Outreach you can do both I mean dude one
post a
day one post a day see who interacts
with it so who likes it who comments on
it you can message all those people and
then you can reach out as well but the
thing is is with your profession finding
someone who has an adjacent audience so
uh you know if someone who's an HR
company or recruiting company right like
if you can figure out a way to just work
with them they already have a whole
engine of people coming in and just see
if you can just get off the backside and
give them a kickback just for intros
like that's a super prod way of uh of
leveraging the amount of reach outs like
you can just reach out to 10,000
business owners and you'll you'll get
your nut but you could probably reach
out to a thousand B2B businesses and see
if you can structure a partnership with
them that they can refer you business
and you refer it back to them either of
those at work okay okay yes content and
Outreach you and real talk the content
is probably not in the beginning where
you're going to get the majority of your
business I just want to just prepare you
for that but the reason that you're
going to be making the content at the
beginning is that so when you do Reach
Out people will go to your page and they
will consume your content and then they
will decide to
respond based on the quality so think
about that stuff as lead nurture more
than lead genen in the
beginning over time you'll get better at
it it'll start generating business but
it might take you a year or two like it
takes time to get good at
that yeah hey thank you so much Alex I I
just want to say thank you so much
because like the past three years I just
listen to the game podcast like all the
time and that's honestly what's got me
through everything but I it just it just
honors me and it makes it makes me so
happy like as a father and as as like a
aspiring entrepreneur to to meet you and
and everything that you do like you've
inspired me and that's the reason why I
took the jump in the beginning so I
appreciate you well I appreciate you for
taking the jump and um I will ask you to
trust me one more time which is that
four hours a day have the conversation
with your wife 10,000 regs awesome she
she's watching so she knows all right
let celese take his 10,000 that's it
like on the other side of 10,000 reach
outs is you making the money that you
want to make and having the skill of
promotion and sales that's it awesome
thank you so much 100 every day rule of
100 I got
it thanks Alex you better
brother life is hard believing it should
be easy makes it
harder
oh
man it was
um Dr CEO Ghost Writer I feel so bad
right now um but you you you had this
issue which was that you said you wanted
to have a thousand books to sell and you
basically made an equation that was if I
don't get X I will be
unhappy and so um I think the first
person I heard this was from nval but he
said
um desire is making a contract to be
unhappy until you get what you
want and so it's like signing a contract
by saying life should be easy and every
moment it isn't easy I will be unhappy
like that makes it more difficult than
just being willing to weather the harder
times and so when I do get down on
myself because I do too I actually had a
pretty sad day I woke up this morning
and I I actually messaged Leila I was
like I'm really sad today I was like I
don't know why I was like I'm just
giving you a heads up um I try and think
what expectation spoken or unspoken am I
making of the universe that I feel is
fulfilled and is that expectation
reasonable and more often than not I can
identify what the expectation is and
once you pull it out and look at it you
think about how ridiculous it is like I
the expectation that I have of the
universe is that I should be able to
sell a thousand books because I deserve
it and by the way deserving is the exact
opposite of gratitude so I am I want to
publicly State wholeheartedly that I am
hardcore against anyone thinking they
deserve anything so people are like get
what you deserve ask what what you want
BL but you don't deserve anything you
can get things for what you do but you
don't deserve them because if you do get
things when you believe you deserve them
then you will not be grateful for them
you will expect them and then it takes
something that otherwise would have been
amazing and nullifies it it's like
spitting on a gift and so I try to take
this perspective of I deserve nothing
and I'm grateful for everything and
obviously that's very hard because life
is about creating predictions and trying
to meet those predictions but as much as
I can be aware of the times where I feel
more anxious or more sad or more angry
or more upset or frustrated it usually
comes down to what expectation my
demanding from life that is unreasonable
and realistically it's almost always
just any expectation that I have of life
that does not care and so um that
perspective and I share that one because
like entrepreneurship sucks a
lot of the time like most of the
day-to-day of Entrepreneurship is just
getting kicked in the nuts every single
day for years years on end with an
occasional glimmer of hope followed by a
swift kick in the nuts and so like one
you have to have pain tolerance but
that's that makes it sound super Alpha
and whatever because I don't really
think it's pain tolerance I think it's
reframing pain as reality and something
to be
expected and the price that we are
willing to pay for the thing that we
want and so it's like the $500 Nikes
it's like you can't be upset that the
Nikes it's like going to the store and
being upset that something costs a
certain price and I know some people do
that which is a great recipe for being
upset all the time but like it's just a
trade you can choose to not make the
trade and that's the thing is like we
have the choice it's voluntary like we
chose to become entrepreneurs we chose
to start businesses and with that choice
comes consequences and one of those
consequences is forever feeling
uncertain and always dealing with pain
and I saw this tweet by Elon Musk
yesterday and I thought it was so
perfect he basically said being an
entrepreneur is always getting I'm
paraphrasing what's left
over it's after everyone's done their
job and then there's the really terrible
thing that no one wants to do guess who
gets to do that
you because it's no one else's business
and it's also no one else's job and so
like the definition of what you are as
the founder or the entrepreneur of your
business is that after all of the tasks
have been done from the people who have
their jobs being done the the the
steaming pile of terrible conversations
that you have to have have those are
yours no one takes those for you and
whenever there's an unknown circumstance
like we've never seen this before gets
who gets to do that you and guess who
gets to mess it up and think about it
for the next five years also you and you
just accumulate these scars until
eventually you see a second one that
reminds you of one that happened three
years ago and you're like o i remember
what I did that time and that didn't
work I will try something different and
hopefully this time it sucks a little
bit less and it's literally that cycle
over and over again until the sucking
just becomes normal because I don't
think like I don't think
entrepreneurship sucks less the higher
up you go I think you just get so used
to it that I mean I I'll tell you a
story
like I remember the first time I had
legal concerns like an employee said
that a wrongful termination or whatever
right and I like you know I had all the
anxiety what if they're going to end the
business what's going to happen now but
then I got the second one and my third
one and my fifth one and at this point
like Elon Musk is always engaged in a
hundred ongoing lawsuits at all times if
you have people will try to take it
from you it is how it works and so if
you if you have never had a legal
concern it means you have never had
anything worth
taking and so it's not that you are
failing it is a sign that you are on the
right
path like you don't have hardship if
you're not moving
forward like the only time that you
truly have no hardship is if you're not
growing like nothing says stagnation
like a comfortable
entrepreneur and so the fact that you're
in pain means that you are growing which
is why they call them Growing Pains like
and that is voluntary because we chose
to become better and part of that
becoming better means breaking the old
self that you had into a thousand pieces
and feeling every single crack that has
to happen and then watching the new
fresh skin come underneath of it
stronger and thicker than
before
all right well Instagram Twitter Youtube
hope you guys enjoyed one of zero live
this was our our first shot at this this
was a uh an experiment we like to try
new things here we're experimental if
you will um and if you guys dug this or
this was interesting for you guys uh
please let us know and if this also blue
let us know and if you if you were like
you know what this part was great and
this wasn't let us know like we take all
feedback we accept all feedback now we
might not do everything you say but we
will absolutely accept all feedback and
so um that's the biggest gift that you
can give us if any of this was valuable
for you the gift that I asked for is
that you let us know how it was um
otherwise I just want you to know and I
and I hope that mation exists here for
this one reason which is that like you
are not alone there are other people
going through it and so despite that it
may feel lonely you were not
alone keep being one of Zero by
n